with dignity and respect
committed to free speech straight
talking and direct we may have to take
each other and you thought provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge as fears grow
about a possible No Deal brexit plans
are being put in place hospitals are
preparing to stockpile medicines
supermarkets are making sure there'll be
enough food well we at the pledge
decided we needed our own contingency
plans to make sure there is no
disruption to your viewing so we're
going to start stockpiling panelists
first into the madhouse we brought in
Trevor Phillips welcome Trevor thank you
lovely to have you here
yeah well coming up I'm making a racket
about the Serena Williams route Michelle
thinks we need to consider offering
treatment to potential pedophiles Gregg
wants a radical change to tackle the
housing crisis and Nick says that
sometimes stereotypes aren't lazy just
true but first let's see what our newest
face around the debating table wants to
talk about let's leap straight in I am
fed up with the media having an attack
of the vapors every time someone uses
vivid language and I think it's time we
stopped having a fit each time Boris
Johnson or Donald Trump throws a verbal
grenade
whether it's Theresa Mays suicide vest
or Muslim women and letter boxes critics
say these words and that's all they are
word cause offense sure they're meant to
but why shouldn't public figures be able
to deploy words that sting and images
that shock indeed when someone let rip
that's exactly how the rest of us get to
understand who they are if you call me
the n-word to my face and I know one
more name off my Christmas card list
people like Johnson and Trump know
exactly how to get everybody
talking about the things they want us to
which is mostly them the rest of us
complain conventional politics is dull
but we're letting the populace take over
no wonder when we're using gags to stop
people from speaking out rather than
making politicians worth listening to
[Music]
Trevor just to remind us and the viewers
we've got a clip here showing the sort
of things that were said this week
I think he's wrong on this I think the
tone that he's used isn't right and I
think that we just need to be very
focused on actually moving forward with
the checkers plan
I think there are much better ways to
articulate your differences and I think
it's a it's a reminder I think for all
of us in the in public policy whichever
political party we represent to use
measured language I don't think his
comments yesterday were were well judged
and I think again returning to the
substance that they think he set out an
alternative approach to brexit
[Music]
when Boris speaks he gets it across in a
metaphor in a very clear way basically
saying the European Union was still
control in United Kingdom
[Music]
see I'm not sure I agree with you I
think there is a problem of debasing the
language I think that when Trump for
instance went through a whole election
campaigns calling her crooked Hillary I
think it devalued the whole thing and I
think once you've got there there's
almost no coming back and that therefore
bit by bit by bit the the language used
and the abuse use between politicians
will get worse and I think I think there
are better ways of saying some of the
stuff at the moment policies he's got a
column every week he needs to keep
himself on the front pages so every week
he writes something that he knows will
create this reaction which is what you
said I think that is damaging to our
politics not an advantage just about
abuse then fine I I would agree with you
but Boris Johnson didn't say something
about another politician he made a
metaphor about something which we all
talked about and to be honest you know
public speaking is really about telling
great stories that other people will pay
attention to and he kind of told a story
to be honest when I listened to the
responses to him what I'm really
thinking is who frankly has remembered
anything I've ever said we can't say
let's make politics let's make our
democracy vibrant and alive but let's
remove the weapon that the politicians
have which is to excite interest from
them what Trump did different thing
direct abuse about a particular
individual that's a whole different
story this is not about that this is
about vivid speech what can I just say
how delighted I am Trevor because when I
saw your name on the team sheet I
thought dear oh dear oh dear I like you
very much but we're just never ever
going to agree but welcome to reality
you are absolutely right and you will
know that Greg is wrong
idea of a metaphor is that it's not
literal
so had Bora and I'd completely support
Boris's comments had Boris said that
they'd wrapped a suicide vest around the
prime minister or they'd wrapped it
around the brexit team that's ugly it's
an inanimate object the British
constitution exists doesn't it again on
the front page so it's perfect and and
trevor is absolutely right it has become
a national pastime now to take offense
we have become an extraordinary nation
of shrinking violence whether it is as
the example that you've quoted there's
either another one which perhaps we'd
let you see this this is some after
Chuck emunah the Labour politician
appeared on Sky News and said that he
felt that the Labour Party was in some
way institutionally racist he was then
under attack from Labour bigwigs and he
responded like this my message to our
leadership is clear it is within your
power to stop this so call off the dogs
and get on with what my constituency one
of the most diverse communities in the
country demands we do after which shadow
chancellor john macdonald said the use
of the word dogs quotes is just
unacceptable did he really think did
does he think chucker thinks he's gonna
be savaged by hounds it's totally
underscores we are too and ultimately
actually we will become just too
precious a nation so well done trevor
and welcome to the show we've got a
great times together can I can I respond
even though I spent most of the last two
weeks trying to avoid talking about the
subject of my brother's remarks and his
high provocative ears I think it was
interesting that in that clip that
almost everybody
the news media found to say how
outrageous he was was a Tory MP who
doesn't want to see Boris Johnson become
Prime Minister I mean you know from Alan
Duncan used to work with him to David
Koch you know they all climbed on that
bandwagon me anyone before on but I'd
like I've got a slightly mates response
to your topic which is that I sat here
and I said that I felt there
harassed and actually upset by some of
the language used about remainders by an
unnamed tabloid newspaper you know you
know enemies are the people about the
judiciary and traitors about the Tory
MPs who didn't support brexit and I find
that language difficult so I don't know
and I find it inflammatory so I'm not
sure whether I totally onboard your bus
that we should be we should have
absolute open season for anyone to say
anything about anybody regardless of the
consequences so because I want to bring
in Trump now to move away from Tory
politicians because he is also very
outspoken and what he said potentially
about the North Korean leader didn't
even give him his name was may be
equally prerogative Rocketman is on a
suicide mission for himself and for his
regime the United States is ready
willing and able when he has his finger
on the nuclear button and you know you
he's talking about an armed and armed
and cocked opponent like Kim jong-un is
that sensible the weapons that
politicians have at their disposal in a
democracy are worse nuclear weapons and
frankly I would rather any word that can
be used rather than Donald Trump
pressing a trigger that sends a weapon
words are the they're the essence of
democracy and it's called invective by
the way this is not just about Tories I
mean to me one of the greatest piece of
invective was used by Denis Healey the
thought the the Labour politician when
he said that being attacked by Geoffrey
Howe was like being savaged by a dead
sheep memorable speech let's prove we're
democratic on the pledge we have
Michelle all words I am with both of you
I can I I agree with both of you in in
part so words defend me at all I don't
get offended I get called names and
everything all day every day on social
media and if I was offended it'd be a
sad day but so I agree with you to the
point where we should
stop being so precious about the words
that people are using and stop being so
quick to be offended but then I also and
I think Boris Johnson is very smart I
think he says a lot of what he says is
purely for column inches purely for
attention and purely to get people
talking about him so but then to the
other side I also think that when I see
for example the President of the United
States calling people little Rocket Man
and I just think it's a bit pathetic I
just think it's I understand the
language I'm not offended by it you know
and I'm sure it's the kind of thing that
people say up and down the in the pub's
but I just think actually if you're
going to be the United at the leader of
the United States I would actually like
you to be able to communicate and
articulate yourself slightly